When discussing how to position
views in the last quiz,
you may have mentioned
using a relative layout.
I know we did.
But I want to introduce you to another
way that you can build the layout for
our app that would be more ideal,
using nested viewgroups.
Nested viewgroups means putting
viewgroups inside other viewgroups.
That way you can build more interesting
and complex layouts like these.
Let's see how you would build
up one of these layouts.
Say, for example, you have a vertical
linear layout with three views,
an image view and two text views.
What if you wanted to overlay
some text on top of this image?
Well, with a linear layout,
you can't overlap views.
But with a relative layout, you can, so
we can replace this child with
a relative layout instead.
Then, we can put the image view
inside this relative layout.
This image view is now aligned to each
edge of the parent relative layout.
So, there you see an example of a
relative layout that's contained within
a larger linear layout.
You can have many combinations of
view groups within other view groups.
For instance, you can have a relative
layout as a root view for an app.
That can contain a couple of views
like an image view and two text views.
You can also add a linear layout as
a child of this broader relative layout.
This linear layout itself can contain
other children like two image views.
You can nest as many view groups
inside other view groups as you want.
However, be careful because
the more nesting that you do,
the more expensive it will be for
your app to lay out on the screen.
The relative layout, in particular, is a
very flexible layout but it can be very
complex to calculate the position of
each of these views relative to others.
So it's recommended to not have
too many layers of nesting
within a relative layout.
I pulled some examples from real life
Google apps to show you some cases where
it would be useful to
use nested view groups.
The Google Now app shows you
cards of relevant information
based on your current situation, like
the current time or current location.
If you like a certain
team like the Red Sox,
good choice, then it can show you
the score for the latest game.
To build out the layout for this card,
you can imagine using a vertical linear
layout because the information
is displayed as rows.
However, the first item in this vertical
linear layout is not just a single text
view, it's made up of multiple views.
In fact, you would build this first
item as a horizontal linear layout,
made up of an image view and
two text views.
Same for the second item in
this vertical linear layout.
You would build it with a horizontal
linear layout containing an image view
and two text views.
Another card in the Google Now app
shows relevant stocks that you
may be interested in.
I wish the Google stock
was still at that price.
Anyways, you can also build out this
layout as a vertical linear layout,
because you can imagine the rows here.
Except these middle entries
aren't just a single text view,
they're made up of multiple text views.
For this line item relating
to the Google stock price,
you could use a horizontal linear layout
and fill it with four text views.
Same for the other stock prices as well.
These horizontal linear layouts
are children of this broader
vertical linear layout.
In the Google Play music app,
you can, of course, listen to music.
While this looks like
a complicated layout to build,
you can actually break it down into
smaller view groups that you recognize.
This pattern feels like
a vertical linear layout
with three different children.
This first child can be built
using a relative layout,
because the views
are relative to each other.
The second child can also be
built using a relative layout,
because the views
are overlapping each other.
And this third child here looks
like a horizontal linear layout
made up of five different buttons.
Again, we can use nested view
groups to build out this screen.
This is just one way to
build out the layout.
You can build it in many
other ways as well.
In the Google Maps app, earlier we
saw that there are detailed pages for
individual locations, like restaurants.
You can't build out this screen
with just a single linear layout or
a single relative layout.
You need to nest a bunch
of view groups together.
On a broad scale,
we can see that the information
is almost organized into rows.
So, we can use a vertical linear
layout as the parent view.
One child could be
this whole layout here.
Another child could be
this row of buttons.
Another child would be this
description and so on.
But within each child is
not just a single view.
We have multiple views.
This child in the broader linear layout
is made up of three individual views.
So you can use
a horizontal linear layout
with equal weights to each view so
that they get spread out evenly.
This child in the broader vertical
linear layout can also be made
up of a horizontal linear layout
with an image view and a text view.
If you keep scrolling this page, you
see more information on the restaurant.
Again, I can imagine the individual
rows of information here.
Using a vertical linear layout for
all this information still works,
and, again, some rows are more
complex than just a single text view.
This row shows a bunch of available
times where you can make a reservation,
and it's made up of three different
buttons that you can arrange using
a horizontal linear layout.
This row of pictures can be built using
a horizontal linear layout as well.
And actually,
within this horizontal linear layout,
this first child is not
just a single image view.
It's an image view with a text view.
So you could use a relative layout
to build out this first child.
So you could see how there can be
view groups, within view groups,
within view groups.
There's actually more view groups
beyond just relative layout,
and linear layout, there's also
frame layout and grid layout.
We're not going to have time to cover
those in this course, but I definitely
recommend that you go out and learn
about them on your own because sometimes
those would be better than just
using a relative or a linear layout.